Success breeds success and failure
breeds failure.
And it's not necessarily linear.
And that's a really difficult thing to
deal with.
And it's hard on societies because one
of the things we do know is that,
you know,
as you stretch out the inequality you
make men particularly on the lower end
of the distribution,
more and more likely to be aggressive.
It's sort of like,
imagine every man has a threshold for
violence.
Um,
and status is important to men,
knocked that it's not important to
women,
but it's different.
It's a different kind of status.
It's status is important to men because
it's one of the things that makes them
marketable as partners to women.
So it actually turns out to be quite
important to man them.
Men tend to compete with one another for
status,
hierarchy position and in a really
unequal society.
If you're like a low rung guy then and
you don't have any opportunity to rise
because the society isn't structured so
that there's mobility,
then the more aggressive guys tend to
turn into criminality and you know,
and so you could say there's a threshold
for criminality and the more inequality
pressure you put on a particular area,
geographic or political area,
the more inequality pressure you put on
it,
the more men slip past that threshold
and into criminality.
And you know,
there's been pretty good studies done of
drug gang in Chicago.
That was the best one.
It's sociologist actually went and hung
out with a drug gang for,
he got into it,
I guess the drug gang leader was,
you know,
I wouldn't say necessarily narcissistic,
but that might be a reasonable way of
thinking about it.
And he was kind of happy with the idea
of maybe being a subject of a book and,
and so this guy was able to associate
with them,
got to know them quite well.
And then the housing project in which
the gang was housed was slated for
demolition.
And the gang broke up and he got the
books because they kept books.
And what he found was the average street
drug dealer,
first of all was employed in another job
as well and was making far less than
minimum wage now.
But the guy is,
you know,
further up the chain of course followed
the Prieto distribution.
And so there was a tiny minority of them
who were raking in a tremendous amount
of loot.
And the guys at the bottom,
we're just waiting around for the
possibility that they could rise up the
hierarchy and you know,
it's pretty violent game.
So the chances that someone is going to
be
taken out is pretty high and then a
little slot up for some opportunistic
second rater and perhaps he can move up
the hierarchy.
Okay.
So the burrito distribution governs all
sorts of other things too.
I mentioned
it governs the popularity of box,
the sales of books,
but it also,
it also characterizes the distribution
of everything that people produce.
So if you think of creative production
of any sort of artistic production,
industrial production,
it doesn't matter.
Almost everything fails.
Yeah.
And a few things succeed beyond anyone's
wildest imagination.
Apple's a good example of that.
No,
I mean the iPhone,
they have their competitors,
but it's an extraordinarily dominant
product and they rake in billions of
dollars,
I think.
I don't know if apple is valued at $1
trillion,
but it's close to that.
And that's a lot of money.
And I think if I remember correctly,
it's something like this,
I probably have the figures wrong,
but like the top 40 people,
the richest 40 people in the world have
as much money as the bottom 2 billion
right now.
You know,
it's not like they're stuffing their
mattresses with that money or they have
a skyscraper full of cash.
That money is out in the economy doing
whatever money does.
So you know,
you can't spend $28 billion.
So,
and sometimes you can even do some good
with it.
You know,
Bill Gates seems to be doing something
reasonable with his money.
But the reason I'm telling you this is
because one of the things you should
know is that this proclivity for
inequality is pervasive among the
creative products of human beings.
It's the case with with goals scored in
hockey.
My son told me,
and he's a reliable source on hockey
statistics that,
okay,
if Wayne Gretzky,
if you don't count any of the points
that Wayne Gretzky managed with scoring
is still had enough points just with
assistance to have more points than any
hockey player that ever played.
So you know,
you even at the upper end of of of the
distribution,
there's some person who's ha there are
so good at what they do and then there's
another person that's so much better
than them that it's not even comparable.
And so,
and the benefits flow to people who are
in that position.
And you can understand why.
I would say,
because I all,
let's say you start writing and you get
a book and a rare things,
very rare things to have happen.
And then some people read it and they
like it.
And then of course it's much more likely
that you'll get a next book.
And if people like that,
while it's even more likely that you'll
get a third book and then people start
to know who you are and then because
they know who you are,
they phone you up on offer you
opportunities and your network grows.
And it's like this exponential increase
in your reach and your capacity for
production and more and more flows to
you.
And,
and then on the other hand,
if you start to fail and you know,
why would someone fail?
Well,
God,
you know,
one idea that's very common in our
culture is that poverty is caused by
lack of money.
And that's a really stupid idea because
money is very difficult to handle.
I have clients who were drug addicts and
the worst possible thing that could
happen to them was that they got some
money,
but they're just done.
First of all,
you know,
they were hanging around with people who
were little on the sociopathic side.
And so,
especially if they weren't that bright
and couldn't defend themselves very
well,
as soon as they got money while it was
off to the bar with all the friends and
you know,
one guy I remember in particular,
every time he got his,
his disability check,
he was gone for five days,
usually found him in a ditch.
You know,
cause he just go to the bar,
spent every sandy had on alcohol and
cocaine and wake up in a ditch,
three quarters dead,
uh,
eventually completely dead.
And you know,
then he was ashamed and horrified and
repentant and he'd straightened himself
out again.
And then that was all well and good
until,
as long as he was broke until the next
check showed up and then bang the same
thing.
So,
you know,
it's not like money is necessarily a
good for everyone.
It's hard manage money.
It's really easy for it to disappear.
I mean,
elderly people have a hell of a time now
because you know,
crooks are contacting them all on the
Internet nonstop.
And so just giving people money,
money's like,
it's like pouring water in their hands
is not that helpful.
Not necessarily that helpful.
And then of course contributors to
poverty are,
well it's not so good to have a low Iq.
You know,
people don't like the idea of Iq because
it seems so arbitrary.
You know you have a high Iq.
Well it's not like you deserve that.
Exactly.
It's,
you set up that way pretty much right
from the beginning.
It's very,
very,
very stable.
You can make a high Iq person stupider
by you know,
not educating them up to the level of
their possibility but taking someone who
has a low Iq and trying to raise that.
It's like if you can figure out how to
do that,
well you know it's Nobel prize time for
you because people have tried that a lot
and most recently with those,
you know Luminol Lumosity games and that
sort of thing.
And the evidence that those produce
anything other than brilliant
performances on the Lumosity game itself
is basically zero.
We haven't been able to figure out how
to see cause I intelligence a cross
domain phenomena and you can get really
good in a single domain by practicing
like mad and what you'd want is to
practice like mad in a single domain and
hope that it generalize to other
domains.
That's the holy grail of intelligence
increase.
It's like,
no,
no one's done it.
People claim it,
but the claims never hold up and people
have been trying for a long time to do
it and they haven't been able to do it.
And
differences in Iq really make a
difference.
You know,
I mean you guys,
average Iq is probably one 25 one 30
at one 15 you're at the 85th percentile
and one 15 would barely get you going
for,
for Harvard University one 30 you're
probably graduate school and material,
you know one 45 you're up there
at the range where you can probably do
pretty much whatever you want.
Although as you get smarter,
the scatter between your abilities
increase it.
So you might have a very high verbal Iq,
but not be so good at mathematics or the
other way around.
But it's a massive contributor to
lifetime success.
And I don't know what to do about that.
I mean,
why do smart people make more money?
Well,
they get to where the edge of production
is faster.
So if you have a thousand people and you
rank order them by Iq,
the smart people are going to come up
with a new ideas first and they're going
to have more ideas and they're going to
strategize better.
And you know,
with an Iq of 90 which is
15% of the population,
you think about that 15% of the
population.
That's pretty much the threshold for
reading instructions and being able to
follow them.